my job as a medium is to deliver
messages i can't stress enough how proud
she is of you do you ever have any fear
of you know re-merging with the new
series like this you know this project
is so different than hollywood medium
i'm going into it i wasn't sure what to
expect i think people will get an
insight into the process of the readings
but also more than that even just a very
intimate look into my personal life
three years ago my mom discovered that
she was taken as a baby the woman who i
actually thought was my mother
was a murderer i want to learn more
about what happened to my mom's family
how did that news impact you when you
first heard that it was really
overwhelming um you know having the
camera crew there to capture that
journey for me was really cathartic but
also very intense i mean my mom didn't
even know if her given name was her name
she didn't know if her birthday was
really her birthday and in her 50s she
was having to assess her identity and
where she came from and who she was and
myself as well as a media my life is
defined by moments of trying to help
people find a sense of peace is there a
reading from a celebrity that has just
kind of stayed with you this entire time
on your life i think of my reading with
rupaul as being probably one of the most
fulfilling for me he was somebody who i
looked up to as you know a gay kid
growing up in a small town and then so
to be able to meet him and not only meet
him but help him and give him
some clarity around something he never
thought he would get it kind of came
full circle for me you know when i
performed for her when i was a kid
she i could do anything in the living
room i could do anything it was always
great no matter how terrible i was it
was always great would you say that
having this ability
in any way affects a relationship
because in my mind i'm like oh my gosh i
could never tell a little white lie
because you would be on to me
no i i can still be tricked and
definitely i'm not all-knowing i was
really lucky when i met clint i knew
that he was somebody who was going to be
in my life for a long time i knew that
there was a resonance there and i'm
better for it so i'm really thankful
it's such a gift that tyler has i never
thought that i would get this experience
everything he said was spot on when you
go to the other side what do you want
tyler's legacy to be people often ask me
you know if i'm afraid of dying and i
always tell people i still look both
ways when i cross the street right i
want to stay alive as we all showed if
anything my work with the other side has
given me more of a clarity about life
and what really matters and what's worth
dedicating our energy to and equally
what's not and i think the more we can
kind of make something of our lives in
the year than now the less regret we're
likely to have in the future
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos